it's very important and crucial to
establish closer link between the
cohesion policies Europe 2020 strategy
and also what we face in many European
countries the problem of unemployment we
are against implementation of any macro
economic conditionality especially in
the cohesion policy now if something
like that were to happen we would
support the implementation of this
procedure for all policies across the
board in EU macro economic condition
allottee I think we are union based on
the rule of law and therefore macro
economic condition ality should be in
the DNA of what we do I of course would
like to push it further than just the
cohesion funds but we'll see if it's
legally possible on macroeconomic
condition allottees we do not support
these conditionalities but if this will
be decided upon they should be equally
applied to all European policies for
that consolidation at a time of
budgetary consolidation for some member
states in fact for all Member States we
cannot see how you can defend these
substantial increases in the Commission
proposal we have a safety net for those
countries that will fall out of the
maximum level of support but we also
need to have a reverse save it the net
that the over a ceiling of the
Commission proposal is too high all
headings must contribute to the
necessary cuts but in this context it
must be taking into account that the
Commission proposal sets a nominal
freeze in the sea of CIP we are strictly
opposed to the reverse safety net this
is a further tool to cut the EU budget
at the benefit of the benefit of the
wealthiest member states it's unfair and
unjust it undermines the objective
criteria of allocation means the
transfer of funds from least developed
member states to the wealthiest ones and
contradicts the rule that funds should
be allocated based on
needs and I would like to be very clear
here cohesion policy should not be the
victim of any cuts in the mff for that
for us it would be totally unacceptable
unconvinced that cohesion policy is a
tool for win-win situations basically we
want to stick as closely as possible to
the commissioners proposal we thought it
was already a compromise at the outset
and we want to work so that the European
Council can talk about this at the same
time as it's talking about other ways of
supporting growth and job creation in
that unemployment is an essential
variable in the allocation of the
cohesion funds and we should increase
the unemployment premium and will youth
unemployment should be brought in as a
criteria for allocation now people here
have referred to better spending I think
we should change it to better and fair
spending we need to ensure fee approach
and equal treatment by avoiding the
substantial differences between the
highest and lowest level of direct
payments in value about a level of the
budget Sweden would like to see a real
freeze of the expenditure ceiling which
is significantly more than 100 billion
below the Commission proposal that
should define the budget constraint and
to achieve this we require determination
and courage to make some real extensive
cuts where necessary and we also need to
give priority to urgent expenditure that
really brings added value European added
value to 2 to the budget I don't need to
say much except that we support the idea
of having euros in current terms payment
appropriations and the rolls are also
vital points when looking at the
organization of the proposal on cohesion
and thus EAP the cohesion policy should
remain a strong EU policy focused
primarily on the less developed areas in
spite of the Commission's proposal which
we welcome slovenia still faces one of
the biggest drops in cohesion policy
founding among all Member States we are
in favor of the connecting Europe
facility
though it's a good opportunity for us to
experiment with the so called project
bonds as pilot project and we feel that
we should emphasize and encourage
initiatives in sectors where we can
encourage growth and jobs and the future
of cohesion policy has to be framed in
the context of the current economic
downturn and the increase in
unemployment the challenge for an
integrated cohesion policy indeed for
all EU policy interventions must be to
deal with the crisis as a matter of
urgency a large chunk of savings has to
be found in cohesion policy because it's
such a huge budget not only because it's
such a huge budget but also because we
need to refocus cohesion policy on its
original purpose create opportunities
for less developed regions to converge
towards EU average that way believes
that the focus of the discussion should
not be on the size of the budget but
rather be on better spending by better
spending I understand focused and
efficient policies this will promote
growth and prosperity on the basis of
solidarity among member states and with
a view towards reaching EU 2020 goals
the cohesion policy is a key policy for
investing out of the crisis it's also a
lament how to reach our ambitious Europe
2020 objectives and sometimes we forget
about it but it is also at all how to
strengthen our internal market we want
to say more austere budget but with a
much greater proportion of funds going
to the poorer member states and yes that
does mean a sacrifice by the richer
member states including by the United
Kingdom in order to make that possible
your budget is first of all for
investments and so I agree with their
with a compromise proposed by the
commission on overall sight of it our
resources need to be spent where they're
most needed and cohesion cohesion for us
is the most direct way to growth and
employment in fact Portugal already uses
three-quarters of its structure
funds in smart policies and we would
like to use even more we consider the
cohesion policy as genes the instrument
for delivering the objectives of Europe
2020 strategy particularly for the
country's central regions with the
lowest income per capita the Commission
in its proposal on cohesion policy does
not satisfactorily address Malta's
unique situation as no distinction is
made for a region such as Malta which
has already benefited from one
programming period at convergence status
and which will lose the status only deal
to the statistical effect of the
accession of Bulgaria and Romania the
simplification of community spending in
cohesion and the c.a.p that's one of our
priorities and we feel that there has to
be put into practice alongside a
proportionality that we needed should
keep in mind that of course investment
spending money in the cohesion countries
perhaps much more growth then if you
invested same in a saturated market with
a port fair and objective criteria for
distributing rural development funds
there should relate they should relate
to the priorities of rural development
policy into the real needs of member
states for sustainable development while
Croatia supports the convergence of
direct payments between member states we
strongly advocate the position that the
decrease in convergence should not apply
to Croatia before the end of 10 years
transitional periods in other words only
at a time when Croatia will start to
receive the full amount of direct
payments I see that we start to become
or become more concrete about the macro
economic condition ality I note that
hardly anyone calls for its elimination
you have been constructive in proposing
what could change in the Commission's
proposal in order to make it operate
better and make it more acceptable for
you